El euro es como el TINDER de las divisas.
A todo el mundo le encanta criticarlo pero,
a la hora de la
verdad, mucha más gente de la que pensamos
termina utilizándolo. Estoy seguro de que
todos vosotros
habréis escuchado a economistas y expertos
de todo tipo predecir el fin de la moneda
única europea.
“Lo mejor que podría hacer Alemania para
Europa sería abandonar la moneda única pero
no lo hará” Larry
Elliott para The Guardian
“El Euro es flagrantemente imperfecto desde
su construcción y sus arquitectos ya lo sabían
en el momento
de su creación” –George Soros
Sin embargo, la realidad es muy distinta.
Al final de este vídeo vais a ver cómo el
Euro es tan sólido
como el dólar estadounidense. Prueba de ello
es, a día de hoy, es la segunda divisa de
reserva
internacional ¿Creéis que estoy loco? ¡Para
nada! La tercera parte del comercio internacional
se realiza
utilizando el euro como moneda de intercambio.
El 20% de las divisas de reserva de los bancos
centrales están denominadas en Euros. Y el
Euro es la
divisa en la que muchos países emiten su
deuda.
¡Pero aquí no termina la cosa! Si seguís
VisualPolitik todas las semanas, ya sabéis
que Donald Trump está
poniendo toda clase de aranceles contra el
comercio internacional ¿Y eso qué significa?
Pensadlo bien: si
Estados Unidos va a comprar menos cosas en
el extranjero, habrá menos dólares en circulación.
Sin embargo
¿A que no adivináis quién está firmando
pactos de libre comercio con todo hijo de
vecino? ¡Exacto! La
Unión Europea. Ya han aprobado un tratado
con Canadá, el llamado CETA ¡Pero no es
el único! En los
últimos dos años, Europa ha reducido aranceles
con Japón, México y muchos otros países.
En otras
palabras, cuanto más cosas compremos en el
extranjero, más euros habrá circulando por
el mundo. Es decir,
que puede que lleguemos a un punto donde en
lugar de tener UNA divisa hegemónica, tengamos
2, el EURO y
el DÓLAR estadounidense.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando ¿Todo esto
para qué sirve? ¿De verdad es útil que
el Euro sea la divisa
hegemónica? Pues… sí y, a la vez, no.
Si eres europeo y, por ejemplo, tienes una
empresa, el hecho de que
el Euro pueda ser la divisa hegemónica te
afecta más bien poco.
Ahora bien, para los gobiernos europeos
es una ventaja descomunal. Si hay mucha demanda
de euros, el Banco Central Europeo tiene un
mayor margen
para imprimir dinero sin que se devalúe la
moneda.
De todas formas todo esto lo explicamos mejor
en nuestro vídeo sobre el dólar. Si no lo
habéis visto
todavía, encontraréis el link en la descripción.
Porque la pregunta de este vídeo es ¿Qué
ventajas tiene el EURO sobre cualquier otra
divisa? Por ejemplo
¿Qué tiene el EURO que no tenga el YUAN
chino? Y lo que es más importante… ¿Por
qué tantos economistas
critican el EURO y por qué creemos que se
equivocan? Hoy vamos responder a estas preguntas
pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia.
CRISIS EXISTENCIAL
En los años 70, los países europeos ya comerciaban
entre ellos con toda la comodidad del mundo.
Todavía
no existía la Unión Europea pero teníamos
una cosa muy parecida, el Mercado Común.
Sin embargo, había un
problema. Cada país tenía su propia moneda.
Y cada moneda funcionaba de un modo totalmente
distinta. Por
ejemplo, el marco alemán era una moneda fuerte
y estable. Sin embargo, la lira italiana estaba
devaluándose contínuamente. Así que imagínate
la situación. Eres un banco alemán y le
prestas 1 millón de
liras a una empresa italiana. En ese momento,
el millón de liras se cambia por 1000 marcos
alemanes. Sin
embargo, cuando la empresa te va a devolver
el dinero, la lira se ha devaluado. Así que,
aunque te
devuelvan un millón de liras, cuando lo cambias
a tu moneda, te dan 900 marcos alemanes ¡Vamos!
¡Que has
hecho el negocio del siglo! Pues bien, para
evitar esto, los políticos europeos se juntaron
en una
habitación y... por lo visto probaron sustancias
un poco raras.
Llegaron a un acuerdo titulado la Serpiente
monetaria en el tunel. La serpiente representa
las
fluctuaciones de las divisas, que suben y
bajan... como... una serpiente. Pero para
que no suban ni bajen
demasiado, ponemos un túnel. Eran los años
70, una época loca donde Bob Marley estaba
vivo y la gente
llevaba pantalones de campana.
Conclusión ¿Sirvió esta... COSA para algo?
Obviamente no. Las divisas subían y bajaban
como si fueran una
serpiente borracha. Así que décadas más
tarde, los políticos europeos se volvieron
a sentar. Era el año
1992 y a este acuerdo le pusieron un nombre
con Dios manda. Lo llamaron el Tratado de
MAASTRICHT. Y aquí
sí que se pusieron serios y dijeron: “Se
acabó la tontería: vamos a crear una divisa
única para todos.
Fuera tasas de intercambio, fluctuaciones
y mandangas… ¿Qué dices Gran Bretaña?
¿Qué tú no quieres? ¿Qué
te quedas con tu Sterling Pound esa? ¡Pues
mira, Gran Bretaña, haz lo que te de la gana!”
Y así es como comenzó un proceso de 3 etapas
para crear la moneda única. En 1999, todas
las bolsas
europeas ya cotizaban en EUROS y poco tiempo
más tarde, los ciudadanos europeos empezamos
a usar euros
para todo. Y aquí es donde comenzaron las
primeras críticas.
Europa ejemplifica una situación desfavorable
para una moneda común. Está compuesta de
naciones
distintas, que hablan distintos idiomas y
tienen distintas fronteras, con ciudadanos
que tienen más
lealtad a su propio país que a un mercado
común o a la idea de Europa. –Milton Friedman
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cuál es el problema
con una moneda única? ¿Qué tenía Milton
Friedman contra el euro?
Pues muy fácil. Si tenemos una moneda única,
ese banco alemán del que hablábamos antes
ya no tiene
problemas a la hora de prestar dinero a la
empresa italiana o griega ¿Qué ocurre entonces?
Que como no
hay riesgo de divisa, los bancos alemanes,
que tienen mucho dinero, se lo prestan a las
empresas
italianas, griegas o españolas que lo necesitan.
De repente, los países ricos se dedican a
invertir en
los países pobres como si no existiera mañana.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Dónde está el problema?
Pues el problema llega con la crisis.
Los bancos alemanes deberán aceptar mayores
pérdidas en los préstamos griegos, dice
el ministro de
finanzas alemán
Básicamente, las economías del Sur de Europa
son más pobres y más débiles. Cuando llega
una crisis, sus
empresas son las primeras en caer. Y si una
empresa no puede devolver los préstamos,
el banco puede caer
también. A esto lo llamamos el “riesgo
de contagio”.
Y eso explica que, durante la crisis, hubiera
tantos políticos y economistas que proponían
abandonar el
euro. Muchos llegaron a hablar de crear dos
divisas distintas: un euro para los países
ricos, que sería
sólido y estable, y otro euro para los países
pobres. Un euro que se podría devaluar como
si no existiera
mañana. Sin embargo… a día de hoy, el
Euro sigue vivo y coleando ¿Por qué? Ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver.:
¡VIVA EL KAOS!
Los críticos tienen razón: el Banco Central
Europeo, BCE por sus siglas, es una auténtica
torre de Babel.
Funciona de una forma parecida al Gobierno
de un País. El presidente, que ahora es Mario
Draghi, y su
comité, son el poder ejecutivo. Pero también
tenemos un equivalente al poder legislativo,
el llamado
CONSEJO DE GOBIERNO. Aquí es donde están
los representantes de todos los países de
la Zona Euro. Hay un
representante de España, uno de Francia,
Alemania, Eslovenia… en fin, todos los países
de la Eurozona. Y
estos son los que realmente toman las decisiones.
Los que dicen si se suben o se bajan los tipos
de
interés o si se imprime más o menos dinero.
Y para eso se tienen que poner de acuerdo.
¡Y aquí es donde viene el problema! Los
países del Sur de Europa quieren imprimir
más dinero y los del
Norte no. Y como no se ponen de acuerdo, es
casi imposible hacer decisiones drásticas.
Todo esto es cierto. El problema es… ¿Dónde
está el problema? ¿Dónde está el problema
en que una moneda
no pueda devaluarse porque los que la imprimen
no se ponen de acuerdo? ¿No sería, más
bien, una ventaja?
Os lo hemos dicho mil veces aquí en VisualPolitik,
la mejor divisa es la que menos cambia. Si
el valor
del dinero tu puedes hacer tus compras sin
miedo a que suban los precios de un día para
otro. Y tu puedes
montar tu empresa tecnológica porque sabes
que puedes invertir a largo plazo. Y diréis
¿Pero tan estable
es el EURO? Pues mirad esta gráfica. Aquí
podéis ver la oferta de masa monetaria, lo
que llamamos el
índice M2, del Banco Central Europeo y la
de la Reserva Federal estadounidense ¿Veis
cómo van,
prácticamente, de la mano? En menos de 20
años de historia, el Euro se ha convertido
en una moneda tan
sólida como el dólar. De hecho, en Europa
se nos ha olvidado completamente lo que es
la inflación.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la Reserva Federal
Estadounidense tiene dos grandes objetivos:
mantener la
inflación baja pero, a la vez, maximizar
el empleo. Sin embargo, el BCE sólo tiene
un único objetivo:
estabilidad monetaria. Y, las cosas como son,
lo han cumplido a rajatabla.
Así que bien, podemos decir que el EURO es
una moneda tan sólida y abundante como el
dólar pero… ¿Podría
llegar a ser incluso más sólida y abundante?
Y la respuesta es que sí.
A día de hoy, la Eurozona tiene alrededor
de 320 millones de habitantes, casi los mismos
que Estados
Unidos. Y aunque la economía Euro es más
pobre que la norteamericana, la eurozona se
puede ir ampliando a
medida que entren nuevos países. En los últimos
10 años, 6 nuevos países se han incorporado
al EURO. Y
aunque el clima político no es favorable,
no es descabellado pensar que países como
POLONIA o los
Nórdicos podrían terminar usando la moneda
común en un futuro.
Por si todo esto fuera poco, hay muchas otras
monedas que están ligadas al EURO ¿Recordáis
este otro
vídeo donde hablábamos de las colonias francesas
en África? Allí os contaba que en países
como Costa de
Marfil o Senegal usan una divisa que se llama
el Franco CFA. Divisa que está ligada al
euro. Hablamos de
más de 150 millones de personas, en economías
emergentes, que usan una divisa ligada al
EURO y que
guardan parte de sus reservas en Europa.
En otras palabras, que con tanta gente usando
euros en su día a día, hay suficientes billetes
como para
que las empresas de todo el mundo puedan conseguir
divisa fácilmente.
Pero ya sé lo que estaréis pensando alguno…
Que sí, que vale, Fonseca, que hay mucha
gente usando euros
pero… ¿Sabes que otra moneda se usa mucho?
¡El YUAN chino! Ese RENMINBI que cada día
está más de moda
¿Por qué vamos a usar EUROS en lugar de
RENMIMBIS? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LOS PROBLEMAS DEL YUAN
¡Tenéis toda la razón! China está llena
de chinos. Chinos que usan Yuanes, también
llamados RENMINBIS,
para sus transacciones diarias. Eso significa
una demanda enorme de divisas. Y divisas abundantes.
En
principio, con esto bastaría para que el
YOAN pudiera ser una divisa de reserva ¿Verdad?
Bueno… hay un
problema.
China pone un limite equivalente a 15.000
dólares para el dinero que puede sacar una
persona con su
tarjeta
Tal cual como lo oís: a China no le gusta
que los Yuanes salgan fuera del país. Así
que hay toda clase de
controles de capitales. En otras palabras,
que conseguir Yuanes en el mercado internacional
no es tarea
fácil.
Lo veíamos en este otro vídeo: China quiere
evitar que los empresarios chinos saquen su
dinero del país.
Y para eso, el Banco Popular Chino pone toda
clase de restricciones.
Y como os podéis imaginar, en una dictadura
como China, es difícil creer en la independencia
de su banco
central. Vamos, que si Xi Jimping lo necesitara,
podría cambiar al gobernador del banco y
ponerse a
imprimir billetes a su antojo.
¿No me creéis? ¿De verdad pensáis que
el sistema político no afecta a una divisa?
Pues esperad a las
próximas semanas. Pronto vamos a sacar un
vídeo hablando sobre TURQUÍA y la megadevaluación
que están
sufriendo. En ese vídeo vais a descubrir
lo que pasa cuando mezclas autoritarismo y
crisis económica. Si
no os lo queréis perder, no os olvidéis
de suscribiros a VisualPolitik.
Mientras tanto, os dejo con esta pregunta
¿Creéis que es posible que el EURO llegue
a ser tan importante como el dólar? ¿O tal
vez llegará una nueva crisis que termine
llevándose por delante a la moneda europea?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, recordad que podéis apoyar
este proyecto a través de nuestra página
de PATREON, donde además, accederéis a contenido
exclusivo y un montón de cosas más.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE,
compartidlo con vuestros amigos y… nos vemos
en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto!